vraiment je t'aime beaucoup mais là on
parle quand on démarre comme ça c'est tu
vas prendre plein la gueule
les mots ont un sens effectivement dans
ce tweet là il ya de la violence on
parle de collabo on parle de my tho moi
qui conduis entendre qu'en france ça
commence à me saouler ni rien pendant
barre en tête qui dit des conneries qui
dit qu'on est une dictature qui
combattent dans l'atlantique on passe
qui combattent en pareil cas
non mais ne pensent pas comme
tu dis des conneries tu sais pas de quoi
tu as déjà insultés miracle mais j'ai
passé le thème du goût de kaboul ça
c'est lui qui fait des appels à la haine
au palais des
mariages ne pas dire ce qui se passe non
message à droite parlent et c'était
parti doit publier ce côté toi et qu il
a l aile droite pourrir la vie des gens
en béton faut enlever les allées les
indemnités chômage aux jambes elle tout
d'elle pas procéder du jury c'est d'une
violence incroyable et vous vous êtes la
reprenne le débat parce qu'il a eu à peu
atypique est venu lire vous serez vous
savez ce que nous on vit depuis des mois
et des mois
[Applaudissements]
le même le fait même venir myriam puisse
lire ça devant 2 millions de
téléspectateurs à la télévision c'est
qu'on soit bien clair aux dictatures et
béatrice je voudrais juste dire que je
suis contre toutes les menaces toute la
violence déjà il faut toujours vous êtes
chrétien travaux pas toujours j'oserais
dire aussi que je trouve que dans cette
crise toutes les digues de la décence de
l'humanité de base ont sauté et quand on
est dans un contexte où il ya des gens
qui ont perdu leur job qui sont
suspendus ne peuvent pas nourrir leur
famille ça se joue vraiment avec la vie
les instincts primaires des gens et
quand quelqu'un comme vous monsieur qui
n'avait pas l'air d'être dans le besoin
aller sur un plateau elle est avec une
notoriété est appelée allen clairement
parce que c'est un appel à l'est non non
alors que des gens géniaux s'est énervé
la triste venise opinion justinien
laisser finir mais après s'il vous plaît
laissez leur dire que je trouve ça
incroyable aussi au delà du débat pro ou
anti vaccins pour l'instant ces gens
n'en ferais n'y aucune loi donc ils se
retrouvent plus de job des gosses
peuvent plus aller au foot peuvent voir
leurs potes peuvent plus aller au ciné
avoir une vie d'enfant normal vous leur
pourrissent et déjà la vie en soutenant
une politique extrême ne suis pas une
politique c'est une politique et on a
tendance à madame légende alors je vais
rebondir jusqu'au
suspect allez-y bea n'avait pas quitté
pas tout vous aussi vous voilà qu'on ya
vous mettez des gens dans une situation
ils peuvent plus nourrir leurs enfants
et parce que je ne dis pas que c'est
bien je ne dis pas que je cautionne jeu
c'est toujours ce qu en l aude at-on
estimé jeudi que
ces
textes on peut pas s'étonner derrière
que vous vous preniez des insultes ou
des menaces quand vous pousser les gens
au désespoir c'est extrêmement dans le
jeu we were in syria mais revenue sur
play myriam tu t'es calmer ma chérie tu
sais qu'on t'aime beaucoup ici on te
laisse énormément la parole merci
benjamin voilà tu as dis un truc c'est
pas pour ça qu'ils t'aiment pas voilà on
est là là là je te sont à fleur de peau
ma chérie le débat il ya un truc qui me
choque un homme et oui mais
oui mais mal à l'aise paris nadal a
laissé parler à tabac les autres par les
70's et la part dieu question voulait
dire toi on jouait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je moi je les analogies avec
le play les nazis les juifs ou sage je
ne peux plus entendre ça en travaux
comme on est d'accord
la mairie a m'a jamais dit ça attendez
vous possédez votre balade idéale at
elle dérapé encore autant à tout on
parle de collabos des nations mais je
répondrai après je respecte son choix
c'est bien c'est un choix que je
respecte mais arrêter on est d'accord
avec ça je dois faire